if you're looking for rumors spoilers
and leaks about no time to die you've
come to the right place grab your
martini and load your Walther PPK
because here's everything we know so far
about the next double-oh-seven film
details about no time to die have been
scarce but we do have a very minimal
plot description here's how IMDB sums it
up bond has left active service his
piece is short-lived when his old friend
felix leiter from the CIA turns up
asking for help
leading bond onto the trail of a
mysterious villain armed with dangerous
new technology it's generic but it does
give us some hints about where the plot
could be headed if this is truly Daniel
Craig's final run as bond the one last
job trope could be rearing its head the
movie is expected to arrive in theaters
on April 8th 2020 and it'll be directed
by Carrie Joji Fukunaga who's best known
for helming Netflix's maniac and the
first season of true detective and the
writing team consists of Fukunaga Neal
Purvis Robert Wade Scott Z burns and
Phoebe Waller bridge like some of the
other actors who've played vond
Daniel Craig has a complicated
relationship with the character he's
been praised for his performances and
the franchise has made him an
international superstar and a very rich
man however the grueling pace and
workload of an international film series
has taken a toll on him both mentally
and physically
Craig is no longer a young man and he
suffered injuries from working on the
Bond films that have required surgery it
also seems that he doesn't necessarily
enjoy playing the role anymore in a 2015
interview with Time Out London he
claimed that he would rather slash his
wrists than play Bond again after
Spectre and that if he did do another
Bond movie it would only be for the
money he certainly wasn't lying about
that last part as he's reportedly
bringing in a whopping 25 million
dollars for no time to die
hopefully that much cash Coke's is out
is a game there are a lot of elements
that contribute to making an epic Bond
film and one of the most important is a
memorable villain great bad guys can
make a not quite great double-oh-seven
flick at least entertaining or they can
elevate an already good film to
legendary status no time to die is
swinging big with its baddie in
listing the services of rami malek fresh
off his Oscar win for Bohemian Rhapsody
we'll be making sure Mr Bond does not
have an easy ride of it in this his 25th
hour
considering the uncertain fate of
Christoph Waltz's Blofeld at the end of
Spectre there is some speculation that
Malick will take a turn as Blofeld
himself possibly as a clone or through
some sort of surgical alteration that is
far from confirmed though and it appears
that waltz himself will also be
appearing in the film so don't count on
Malick playing the iconic villain just
yet Christoph Waltz may not be the only
former Bond villain set to return in no
time to die according to page six Grace
Jones was booked for a small role in the
film as fans of the franchise note Jones
previously played made a bodyguard to
Christopher Walken's max Zorin in a view
to kill and a formidable physical
challenge for bond but she will most
likely not be returning as May Day as
she was completely obliterated by an
explosion at the end of that film
unfortunately it turns out that Jones
was not on the same page as everyone
else on this seemingly cursed production
according to the Sun the actress
reportedly thought she was being offered
a bigger role and she took the small
cameo she was actually given as a bit of
a slight so it now appears Jones won't
be appearing in no time to die after all
no time to die is poised to offer
callbacks to many Bond films of the past
and one of the most iconic locations in
his vast filmography will appear at the
beginning of the story when the film was
announced executive producer Barbara
broccoli said that it'll begin with Bond
enjoying retirement in Jamaica which the
team considers the spies spiritual home
1962's doctor no double O sevens very
first cinematic adventure featured
Jamaica prominently so it seems fitting
that this new film will see bond return
to the idyllic setting to try to live
out a normal life in retirement but we
know that that will be interrupted when
his old CIA friend felix leiter comes
calling to rope him back into the game
to deal with a new threat poor Bond he
just wanted to settle down with dr. Swan
maybe this is why Cregg hates the role
so much he never gets to have nice
things
major no time to die plot points are
still under pretty tight wraps beyond
the fact that it begins with James
trying to get away from the spy game in
Jamaica
the Daily Mail has revealed that mi6 has
moved on without him
the agency has given away the
double-oh-seven codename to another spy
played by leshawna Lynch who's probably
best known as Maria Rambo in Captain
Marvel a source close to the film told
the Daily Mail there is a pivotal scene
at the start of the film where M says
come in double-oh-seven
and in walks lashana who is black
beautiful and a woman Lynch has
discussed how excited she is for the
role partly because she is of Jamaican
descent herself were able to include
them in this British movie and able to
mesh the two cultures much like I grew
up doing I'm British I'm Jamaican at the
same time the Daily Mail source added
that bond of course tries to seduce the
new double-oh-seven
but fails the introduction of this new
double-oh-seven is being attributed to
one of the writers
Phoebe Waller bridge whose hiring was
specifically requested by Daniel Craig
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]